richard van Koppen says yes i have i
grew phobia and would love to hear about
anxiety well that's a that's a rough
thing to have Agra phobia so Agra
phobics get increasingly isolated and
afraid of things outside of their domain
of familiarity and often what happens
with Agra phobia is that people who
develop it or afraid of two things
they're afraid that something is going
to go dreadfully wrong with their health
especially with regards to their heart
so they start to become afraid that
maybe they'll have a heart attack and
that they'll die in public far from a
hospital and that they'll make a fool of
themselves while they're doing it or
well they well they think they're dying
and so it's a combination of two fears
and one is fear of mortality and the
other is fear of social judgment and you
might think about those as the two main
categories of fear that possess people
because one is associated well obviously
with mortality and death and the other
is associated with exclusion from the
group which course can lead to mortality
and death and so the Agra phobics get
the worst of both worlds it's often a
disease of middle aged women but not
always and they're often people who've
been somewhat dependent in their
previous lives and then undergo some
traumatic event like a divorce or the
death of someone close and and at the
same time are perhaps experiencing heart
palpitations that are associated with
menopause that brings ideas of mortality
to mind and that can trigger a panic
attack which is very what would you call
it unpleasant experience to say the
least and then that fear of panic
attacks starts making people avoid and
that's when Agra phobia develops out of
anxiety disorders with panic attacks so
you go out and maybe you go to a mall
and maybe you're in a crowd and maybe
you start thinking about well your heart
beat and about the fact that someone
close to you has died and maybe then you
become aware of your heartbeat and you
start to panic because you feel that
maybe it's the beat is irregular or or
that or that you can't detect it as well
as you usually can and then that makes
your heart accelerate because it makes
you afraid and then you get
or more what would you call sensitive to
that and that makes your heart rate beat
even faster and then you panic you want
to get to the hospital to get checked
out to make sure that you're alright and
then you make your fatal mistake which
is that you avoid going back to the mall
and then you go to the grocery store and
the same thing happens and then you
start to avoid going to the grocery
store then you start to avoid avoiding
the subway or taxis or crowds or
anywhere you might get trapped and
wouldn't be able to get to a hospital
soon you end up avoiding everything and
that's when your life really starts to
become a living hell so the basic way to
treat a agoraphobia there's two ways and
one is to develop some control over
breathing to do progressive relaxation
and the way you do that is that you
start with your you start by
concentrating on your toes and your feet
and then your ankles and then your shins
and your knees you move all the way up
your body and let the tension flow out
of your muscles and regulate your
breathing calmly and carefully so that
you can learn to relax and then you go
out you go out voluntarily and start to
confront the things you're afraid of so
for example if you're afraid of the mall
maybe you go to the parking lot and you
look at the mall and then you walk close
to the door and you look inside you know
and then you go home because that's
enough for one day but you do
progressive exposure and that's the base
one of the basic rules of psychotherapy
is that if you're afraid of something
you progressively and voluntarily expose
yourself to it and that generally it's
the voluntary exposure that's curative
right accidental exposure can make you
worse but voluntary exposure it can be
curative and that's sort of associated
with the myth of the hero and the dragon
you know the hero is the person who goes
out voluntarily to confront the dragon
and overcome it and get the treasure so
if you voluntarily expose yourself to
things you're afraid of like no more
than you can tolerate then you'll find
that you get braver and you learn that
you can tolerate the fear and that can
chase the a agoraphobia back but it's
very important to do it on a regular
basis and if you have agoraphobic a
full-fledged agoraphobic probably
consult professional help
it's a very tricky condition and it can
be very can really impair you badly so
that's what I would recommend hi JP I'm
wondering how the computer program that
rates university courses as worthwhile
or not is coming along well it isn't
rating them as worthwhile it's rating
them as postmodern neo-marxist or not
and it's actually fully developed I was
going to launch it and I didn't I didn't
design it somebody volunteered to design
it and presented it to me and it seems
to work very well I was going to launch
it at the end of August so that this
year's University students could benefit
from it but there was the
Charlottesville event and then I got
busy and I also wasn't feeling great and
so I just didn't hit the window of time
properly but I hope to be able to launch
it for the January incoming class to do
a video about what's wrong with the
university system the many things that
are wrong with the university system and
to launch the website at the same time I
also had people suggest to me that maybe
it wasn't a good idea that it would
increase polarization but I've thought
about that for about a month and a half
and I think that the benefit to the
consumer so that would be the informed
student outweighs any danger of
polarization
besides that something has to be done
because the situation in the
universities is really ridiculous so
alright so let's see what else we've got
here in the chat room DVS sk8er 3 that's
quite a mouthful says I'm studying to be
a teacher but I'm also an introvert
could this be a big problem
can I still be a successful teacher
actually what seems to predict success
of teaching best is intelligence and
conscientiousness that's the data so far
so if you're conscientious then you'll
probably be fine
I mean extra introverts have a harder
time speaking in front of groups but you
can learn to do that you know an
introvert can become a very successful
public speaker may not enjoy it the same
way that an extrovert might but that
doesn't mean that you can't learn those
skills and what I would recommend for an
introvert is the same thing that I do
when I'm lecturing is I never talk to
the whole
you know doesn't matter how big the
crowd is I'm always picking out
individuals in the group and talking
specifically to them so I'll make a
point to an individual and I watch their
face and see if they're nodding and
understanding right because that way you
make contact with the entire audience
and then you know I'll talk to someone
for about 15 seconds or so I don't want
to put them on the spot too much and
then I shift my attention to someone
else and I sort of pinpoint around the
room that keeps everybody in the room
focused on what I'm saying because each
person reflects the entire crowd back to
you and so I would say if you're an
introvert or if you want to speak in
public in general forget about the damn
crowd it doesn't exist
speak to people one at one at a time and
an introvert can do that just fine
so you know that's where your strength
would be and I would say you're much
more likely to be unsuccessful as a
teacher if you don't work hard at it and
if you're not interested in and so if
you're an introvert I wouldn't worry
about that I don't think that that'll be
the biggest problem that you'll face so